if you're an institution today and you
have zero exposure to the cryptocurrency
asset class or market you're violating
your fiduciary duty given that it was
the best performing asset over the last
decade right it has very unique
characteristics when it comes to lower
levels of correlation upside the per
unit of risk that you take by allocating
capital here and so those institutions
that are on 0% exposure have to do what
we call get off zero right each
portfolio is different so some it's 10
basis points 50 75 200 500 whatever that
whatever the basis point number is it's
all about what their goals are what
their current allocations are all of
that but zero is the wrong number
right and so that's much easier I think
for long-term macro investors who have
experience and even expertise in the
alternative space so Dave Swanson is
like a perfect example at Yale but I
think that this is actually true at the
central bank level at the individual
level etc and so let's go into a
hypothetical world where the US central
bank is playing that game of musical
chairs and they sit down and it comes
out that the US central bank bought five
10% of the network on the open market
what happens to Bitcoin the price and
kind of the the macro economic world if
that was to come to light well then
buying 5% would be impossible why people
need to realize that more than 10 more
than 10 million of Bitcoin I believe
somewhere between 10 to 13 million are
like held and not like actively trading
are actively circulating only 3 to 4
million are being actively traded
and as bitcoins price will be increasing
I believe that people will be realizing
that this is some there's there's a
really a financial revolution going here
and this is something to be kept for a
long time relative to the amount of
capital that are sloshing around in
capital markets around the world Bitcoin
is really so small still right and it's
really quite it's really liquid really
and as they even try to buy half a
percent like that very act will raise
the price so much in a vertical fashion
that just buying the next half a percent
will be eight times more expensive and
like this continues compounding in an
exponential fashion it will need to be
done in an extremely stealthy in an
extremely clever in an extremely patient
manner over months over years maybe even
and maybe even then they'll only be able
to get to two two and a half percent a
ballpark right here's what I like to say
government's buying bitcoin really I
think they will be buying bitcoin last
there's two things I want to say here
first of all government's buying bitcoin
will essentially be putting the final
nail in the coffin of reducing their own
size by half because bitcoin is
unprintable which we have discussed how
is going to destroy fiat currencies and
bitcoin is increasingly UNTAC scible I
mean the privacy technologies around
these technologies as you know will also
keep improving rapidly this is
inevitable and so I believe that
government's buying bitcoin will
probably be the latest group of people
to buy them and that will be the final
ultimate credibility because essentially
the biggest competitor is capitulating
something like that will not just be a
rumor something like that given bitcoins
the liquidity will be extremely
difficult to hide I like to joke that
once a and some Asian central bank
oversaw or a sovereign wealth fund
announces that they put 2% of their
assets into the portfolio of blue blue
chip cryptocurrencies it's game over
but it I don't think that central banks
will really the people by the time they
will try to be accumulating any of them
Bitcoin will already be huge I actually
believe and this is one of the things
that my views differ from many people in
the space actually I actually think that
bitcoins our ascent will be driven
predominantly by the wealthy the three
people the three sort of the three
initials of investors that will sort of
make bitcoins price skyrocket over the
coming decades will be open-minded ultra
high-net-worth individuals it will be
savvy funds and fund managers and it
will be I think politicians and
dictators and sort of these fringe third
world second world individuals who will
need this currency perhaps more than
anyone else and I like to joke that the
essentially the people and the
institutions who bitcoin was designed to
destroy will be precisely the people who
will drive bitcoins price and bitcoin
success to the sky because if you think
about it the people who censor the most
need unsensible currency the most the
people who sees the most need
unseasonable assets the most and of
course the people who print the most
need unprintable currency the most these
people every week you read about some
fringe countries wealthy individuals and
government officials bank accounts in
Switzerland in Luxembourg in the
Caribbean being frozen in America being
blocked transactions being censored and
this technology allows those very
precise people to have unseasonable
store value where they can essentially
accumulate wealth with absolutely no one
else in the world being able to take it
away from them so for better or worse
this is how free market instruments and
free market technologies work so it will
be of course used for the good and the
bad but irregardless these very people
who
whose bitcoins if is fighting against
ideologically would be the same people
who will be helping it financially
absolutely and I tend to think that you
are more right than wrong on that right
okay
so before we kind of go into some
rapid-fire questions if an institutional
CIO a central bank authority a
government leader is listening to this
give me your 60-second pitch to them why
they should buy bitcoin bitcoin is the
soundest hardest currency that has ever
been invented in the history of human
civilization it is this disinflation is
second to none its monetary policies
known years in advance and it is
becoming increasingly credible it will
also be increasingly a threat to the
very currencies that you guys control I
think getting in before most other
central banks and most other sovereign
wealth funds and most other rich people
will in the next decade will prove to be
one of the smartest investment decisions
and in the course of human history and
if you are able the countries that are
able to stealthily accumulate bitcoin
and adopt Bitcoin more than other
currencies will thrive in the age of
hyper Bitcoin ization while the other
countries that haven't done so will
suffer tremendously